my name is James Bodecker I'm a
professor of physics astronomy in
biology at the University of Southern
California as a physicist you know
really one of your goals is to
understand kind of the fundamental laws
of the universe and I'm pretty familiar
with Rick and Morty I'm a big fan of
cartoons in general and Rick and Morty
is definitely one of the more sciency
cartoons out there who cares about the
thing you guys are talking about the
whole point of freezing time was to stop
giving a [ __ ] in the episode brickle and
time Rick decides to stop time and as a
result there ends up being multiple
timelines at which Rick Morty and his
sister exist and you know this brings up
a very interesting area of physics is
there even a possibility of there being
a multiverse after the Big Bang there's
kind of an exponential rate at which the
universe increased in size because it's
increasing at such an enormous rate
there might be multiple very similar
universes that kind of coexist and maybe
on sort of different timelines you know
is it possible to move between timelines
these sort of abnormalities in the
space-time continuum wormholes like
would it be possible to go into a
wormhole and somehow come out Kip Thorne
who just won the Nobel Prize in Physics
for gravity waves he postulated that
even if a wormhole world there exists
you know it would basically disappear as
soon as it appeared there's certainly
not strong evidence things like hopping
between universes or even traveling
through time are possible Shari Bree you
created a daycare for my dad the episode
morning night run and they dropped Jerry
off at this Jerry daycare work all these
Jerry's of different realizations of the
universe get together and they're watch
so then the brick and mortar you can go
have fun somewhere else I mean that
brings up in kind of interesting thought
even if there are multiple worlds you
know would you even end up with a lot of
Jerry's on one hand you would say Jerry
seems like such a unique being that
events it would have happened through
the history of that whole universe to
end up with there being a Jerry a very
unlikely but you kind of have the
juxtaposition that with the sense that
because there's so many multi versus
even if only in a very small fraction of
them there might be a Jerry you know
there's certainty that you know there's
twenty Jerry's in existence and they're
all slightly different from each other I
came here accidentally through a
wormhole located in what you call the
Promethean
nebula in the episode there's this
gaseous being that is some sort of
alternative form of life that appears
not to be carbon-based thinking about
what alien life might look like people
also think about you know how my life
actually evolved and the speculation
about the earliest forms of life
I mean carbon wasn't necessarily
involved and certainly when you think
about you know what aliens might look
like I mean there's no strong reason to
think they would necessarily be
carbon-based there's no important
features of life that involve carbon
they could be some sort of gaseous
clouds if life does exist elsewhere that
it wouldn't necessarily resemble what we
know is life on our planet in any way in
the episode Anatomy Park Morty's
actually shrunken he goes inside another
human being to this amusement park that
exists there called the anatomy Park it
seems somewhat physically impossible
he'd have to change the size of atoms
like could you breathe air that was
normal size atoms or would have to be
smaller atoms when they went to the
lungs they actually saw a micro
bacterium tuberculosis which you know
the way they presented is actually
somewhat accurate third of the world's
population is actually infected with
tuberculosis but a lot of times it's
asymptomatic for very long periods of
time you know not only in biology but
also in chemistry and things like
nanoscience we're able to construct
things that exist on very small scales
even smaller than a cell I mean now
we're talking about things that might be
nanometer which is a thousand times
smaller than itself people are now even
in our lab or making nanomaterials
things like quantum dots things like
very tiny wires that are only tens of
nanometers in diameter
I guess they really do have concentrated
dark matter well you know how to make it
- right Rick yeah yeah yeah check the
engine room
another very classic episode of my
opinion and my team aliens and there are
these simoleons that are trying to trick
brick into giving them some secret
recipe to make fuel out of a
concentrated dark energy that's actually
very hot tapping in physics it's a
little mysterious what dark energy or
dark matter might be a lot of these
observations or calculations that we
make about how matter is distributed you
know there seems to be this missing mass
or this missing energy basically people
started calling that dark energy or dark
matter and it's dark because there's
actually at least currently we're not
able to observe it there must be
something that we're missing there must
be something that we're not detecting
and so the idea of using dark energy is
a fuel source I mean that's interesting
because we don't really know what it is
I suppose as we learn more about it or
eventually actually detect it you know
maybe we could somehow put it to some
use it's unclear I'm actually a big fan
of Rick and Morty I think I've seen
almost every episode and they really
dive into somewhat accurate kind of
science or I mean maybe it's slightly on
the edge of science fiction but it's
certainly a modern topics that the real
physicists are grappling with and they
go to work who knows I mean maybe you
know one of these guys doing string
theory calculations I mean maybe the key
insight is really in one of these
working Morty episodes that will really
tie something together that we don't
fully understand yet
you